Ladies and Gentleman. Please direct your attention to the front of the cabin. For your safety please unbuckle your seat belts.
Beverages, beverages, snacks, beverages, beverages, beverages snacks.
Can I stow that for you sir?
Your dad is going to love this! Best summer vacation ever!
I Gotta warn you. I played second team co-ed intramural volleyball at Santa Cruz.
DJ Jazzy Johnny in the house.
♪ There's a place you've gotta be, a thousand leagues beneath the sea ♪
♪ Gonna take you for a ride ♪
♪ But first you gotta come inside. Get ready for the party's on tonight ♪
It's party time!
Surprise! Oh, my gosh. This is gonna be so much fun.
I've taking care of everything. So you don't need to worry. You've been so stressed out lately.
Good evening travelers.
I am professor Abraham Van Helsing. Yes, one of the Van Helsings.
Fear not! For I am a professional.
And I know how to flush out these beasts and bring them into the light.
Finally! First I kill Dracula and then the rest of the monsters.
Welcome to the Bermuda Triangle. Where you'll embark on a monster cruise of a lifetime.
What about here?
That's right. What exactly don't you understand?
Man, this is amazing! There's so much to do.
Whoa, give me a seaweed rewrap.
Whoa, who is that?
I am Captain Erica and yes, I'm human but don't hold that against me.
I could not be more excited to have all of you on board our first ever monster cruise.
So, you must be the one and only Dracula.
That was incredible.
Hey Murray here may be from Egypt. But you're the one in 'de nile' (denial).
Ha ha ha. Do you guys get that?
Ow, you hit me right in the..
Ow! Watch where you're pointing mister. I'm right here
Okay, Drac hit it.
This is like the nicest hotel I've ever been to.
Yeah!
Everybody just please watch the hair. Watch the hair!
Oh, no you don't. Last time you gambled you lost an arm and a leg literally.
Frank would you rub some moon screen on my back before I get burned?
This is Bob. Say hi, Bob.
Whoa! Come on Papa Drac. There you are tinkles. Don't worry almost there
Captioned by The Toons Express. Please sub.